[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to film
independent presents i'm rachel blamer
director of events for film independent
before we get started with today's very
exciting conversation we have to give
praise to our loyal supporters our lead
sponsor the hollywood foreign press
association and our screening sponsor
vision media
with that i'm honored to introduce our
guest moderator she's practically film
independent family at this point please
welcome varieties janelle reilly janelle
please take it from here
thank you so much for having me i'm so
excited to be here for this film
independent q a with old henry and at
this time please join me in welcoming
today's guests we have writer director
executive producer pop c poncerolli and
star tim blake nelson thank you so much
for being here why'd you settle here
up at dawn working the crops rain or
shine you'll discover there's worse
arrangements
paul's a good man why
i ain't him
stop fretting about it
you know i saw what's in the back of
that closet
i've done things i wish i could take
back
[Music]
let's go look for the rider
what's gonna happen will happen quick
you got a lot of fight for a farmer you
have no idea the hell storm you fixing
to let loose
[Music]
consider me properly worn
i uh want to start at the beginning with
potsie i'm just curious what the initial
sparker idea was for old henry because i
know sometimes it's a character it's a
story it's a setting what sort of
compelled you to write this story
uh i mean this one definitely was a
setting uh it was that that location um
you know i i stumbled on that that
little house down in that ridge and
sat out there for you know a few hours
just kind of walking through it and it's
a really you know it's a 100 plus year
old home and it sits on these stones and
um you know it's just a beautiful house
so hanging out and it started to get
dark and
that got a little creepy because it's
out in the middle of the woods and uh
you know i guess the the idea of what
would i do if somebody came up right now
you don't know if you can trust them and
that kind of
sparked the whole the whole thing and um
it wasn't until later that we added the
you know the historical figure aspect to
it um
and that was that was basically
you know
can we can we make this a more
marketable thing by adding you know an
actual historical element to it and uh
this is after everybody's seen so i
guess i can give it away yeah it's i'm
so excited i can finally talk spoilers
yeah right it is it's nice
but uh billy the kid was always one of
my favorite uh western
heroes or
villains either way you want to look at
it and uh it was an easy ad so
so i'm first of all a little surprised
because i thought maybe you built that
house it was just
there that house was there the and it's
funny because the front porch is
actually on the other side of the house
and so we we had talked about
it would it be possible to actually lift
it and flip it around
um but the house is being held together
by termites so i think it would have
just kind of crumbled
so
um so the owner of the land actually let
us knock down an old barn and use the
barn wood to build a porch
we built the
hog pen and all the fencing and
everything so they let us really kind of
make it what we needed it for
for the movie
and when you say you stumbled upon upon
it i assume you just weren't out for a
walk i assume you were like locations
it was it was uh this is you know it's
about 40 minutes outside of nashville
it's a 2 000 plus acre
plot of land that you know they're very
they've shot a bunch you know they allow
people to shoot on their property so we
were scouting for another project and
um you know just kind of
had to take a sidetrack to walk through
this thing so
that's so cool i love that a location
inspired the whole story
yeah yeah so obviously this film doesn't
work without the right old henry um tim
how did the script find its way to you
and what interested you in the role
aside from the title
it's just one of those weird ones that
came over the transom uh
i was cooking dinner one night and
i got an email that said would you want
to be henry in a movie called old henry
uh and and so i i said to my wife well
it happened now i'm playing the
old people
uh
[Music]
and um
and i read it it was very taken with
the
the tautness of the storytelling most of
all
but also with how it explored what
parenting is
because i think that's really at the
heart of the story the relationship
between the father and the son
and so much of what henry
does my character in the film is
motivated
by
his
love for his kid
and as the again the father of three
boys i'm uh that's something that spoke
to me and i thought
potsie had really
um
had really centered
uh a great western with a wonderfully
intimate and in certain ways tender
story and so i said i gotta meet this
guy
and um
potsie and i and his producer shannon
houchins met over zoom and i
i was in
potsie for you um having seen the movie
it's very obvious why tim was cast in
this role but did you write it with him
in mind or at what point did you start
thinking about him
i think it was you know
i i didn't write it within my mind
because i didn't think tim was a
when we had first started this i didn't
think he was a reasonable guest um and i
think because you know tim's been in
everything and i'm a huge fan of his and
it was until i started seeing you know
when you make an indie movie there's a
list of who's worth
what in the back you know you have to
kind of go down that process of who's
worth what
it was you know
none of those names were fitting
because you know this person i don't
know tim just kind of embodied
the whole thing to me and in if you look
at
a picture of billy the kid and tim side
by side they were actually
pretty similar i mean you and tim knows
it's it's very uh
as far as stature and
and size and the idea that
you know this
this person kind of ruled the west
in such a he was a terror you know
people feared him and for that from that
to come from
such an unassuming person i thought was
amazing um i mean unassuming in the
nicest way too
i just want to know what i have to do to
get on that list
[Laughter]
you don't want on that list you're on a
better list
tim um i'm curious who do you think
would win in a shootout billy the kid or
buster scruggs
probably
probably billy the kid because buster
scribes would be too busy uh showing off
[Laughter]
i mean obviously you you played a cowboy
before with buster scruggs did that role
help you at all in preparing for this
one
it did and it didn't i certainly knew my
way around a pistol because of all the
prep work on buster scruggs
but in a certain sense i had to unlearn
all that and start from scratch with
with old henry
because that's really not the guy that
potsy wrote the buster scruggs character
is not who platzi wrote it's almost
the
converse of him whereas buster scruggs
sees the pistol as
uh
as as a
uh a device for show and histrionics
um old henry
sees it as a lethal tool
with which he no longer wants any
involvement and so he approaches it with
a
a measure of regret
um that then
receives as he refamiliarizes himself
with it and then
something else is awakened
uh so it was a start from scratch
situation in many respects but i was
also lucky
to to have done so much work with the
pistol beforehand
and this film is set in a very specific
world of the old west um patsy how much
did you know about this world before
making this film how did you go about
researching and capturing it so well
you know i
thought i had done research you know
i was familiar with the old west and
then when tim signed on
um you know on that first zoom call one
of the things he asked was can we can we
go back into the script and really
work on it and work on the character and
work on and just you know go through it
together i was like and to me that was
an easy answer because you know
i i think tim is an insanely talented
filmmaker and actor and so i mean we
spent
weeks and weeks weeks just kind of
on the phone every day couple hours
watching movies reading books
and just really diving into
the history and the in the
in that
the location and in that part of the
country and just you know who
feeling the kid was and i think we found
a lot um i mean i don't want to speak
for tim but i think we both kind of
really learned who he was and kind of
got a good grip on it and and that was
one of my favorite parts of the whole
process was it was just that that
collaboration in in finding who who
henry was and
um and so you know i think
i know a lot more now on the on the old
west
we prepped together potsie and i for
months on this and
and i think we probably had as much fun
if not more fun during the
the prep and the research and and
the decision making process between
writer director and actor
that can hopefully go along with the
director of course always having the
last say
um
then you know i think we had more fun
with that process
almost than we did actually shooting the
movie uh it was exciting except for you
diving through the window that was right
this is a fun day
uh it's such a luxury to
to work with a director like foxy who
really wants to
collaborate in that way because he just
loves every aspect of the process so
much
was there anything that either of you
learned about billy the kid that kind of
surprised you or maybe everything
surprised you maybe you didn't know that
much going in
uh i would say everything i knew very
little about it
uh and so the research process was an
absolute delight
uh and that's everything from his
biography
to his his strange code of ethics which
is a combination between i don't know
anton sugur and
and
abraham and job
but but also the physical life of the
guy
as described but also as is evident in
the one photograph of him and and
puzzling that out um over a period of
months because we had that luxury
was one of the most exciting processes
as an actor i've ever gone through
but what about you ponzi
yeah i mean i think the
you know i i
grew up on young guns and and just the
you know i'd done deep dives before into
did he get away was he you know did
pacquiao let him go but i think the
biggest thing that stood out to me in
reading
you know especially pat garrett's book
on billy the kid it was
he was
the kid was such a
he just never gave up no matter what so
if he was in a fist fight and he got
beat up
he would never stay down he would you
know he'd stand up with a rock come back
with that or come back with a
log or whatever whatever he needed to do
to win
um and you just couldn't keep him down i
thought that was that was a really cool
piece to him that
um
that i think shows at the end here you
know it's no matter what the odds are
he's just and he gets so excited you
know it's it's such an adventurous
spirit in him to
to go after that and to go you know to
enjoy the odds being stacked against him
um which i think
is a fun fun aspect to him
is there really only one photo of him in
existence
i was gonna say the same thing i i'm
sure it's
it's it's really cool that it's a posed
picture it's not a candid shot
so it's you know it's it's what he put
forward for us to see
and kind of seeing what that is is
what his version of that was was pretty
cool
that's exactly what i was about to say
so there's there's a lot of psychology
in it too
uh i want to talk about the rest of this
amazing ensemble i want to start with
gavin lewis who plays wyatt
where did you find him and and you know
when you're putting together a family
and you're saying okay this is going to
be your son who you've known his entire
life um was there any sort of a
chemistry read between him and tim or
you know do you just have to sort of
trust the process
gavin came uh in an open audition we had
uh we saw just a bunch of a bunch of
kids and
um
you know he he his first
first read just really hit me
just because he had the emotional part
of it um and he
i think out of
it it just kind of happened that he does
look a little more modern
um you know with his his young
timberlake hair and um
he has
uh he's just a really good actor and and
i think
it sort of fit though that because there
were a couple couple other guys that
were a little more
felt a little more old-timey would fit
into that world a little more but i like
that gavin
did have a more modern look and
the idea that
you know henry's whole job is to
keep his son from the modern world
that's slowly encroaching on them um i
kind of like that he he had that look to
him and
um i don't know
his height
the idea that trace could be his uncle
that that fit there so there are a lot
of things that fit with gavin um
you know he just i think he just got the
he just got the character i think he did
a really amazing job
um and even with him he was in any onset
gavin's the nicest kid i mean he's just
such a delight to have on set
tim you've
thought no he's great i mean you know i
i thought you found him at the schwab's
drug store
he's a friend of the family uh no he's
great and and i um
it was a natural relationship between us
because he
looked at me as a grizzled character
actor
and so that that
and all that attends it was was carried
on the screen in really nice ways he's a
wonderful wonderful young actor
you don't think he might have been like
a little bit unintimidated working with
you
um
if he was that probably wasn't a bad
thing but i don't think so i
you know i i i really um
because i came in
uh
to a very big role
um in in in oh brother where are thou
from
almost complete obscurity and was
treated so well
by george and
uh john
um and holly hunter and john goodman
you know i i've always tried to return
that uh to to actors
um who might come on to a set and and
think oh he's been in so many movies and
um i'd like to do everything i can to
to give actors younger actors the
welcome that i got
it's the very very very least i can do
um and
um
almost all the young actors i've ever
met are really cool decent
uh people anyway so it's not difficult
uh some of the other cast members i
think steven dorf is fantastic in this
and trace adventures he's the one that
you met at the schwab's drugstore
i actually
i met him in libra's fork in nashville
at uh
at a um
it's kind of like a
old-timey
bar restaurant
general store so you're not far off
like you ran into him or you had a
meeting there
so he got in the script he read it and
he liked it he loved that tim was a part
of it and he just wanted to meet you
know and have a couple beers and just
get to know me and hear what we thought
so
um so it was a general store
um and nobody nobody dies on screen like
stephen dorff it's pretty good
he's got skills in that in that
department
trace adkins is fantastic too and
apparently i i'm
naive i didn't realize he has like a
pretty um extensive acting resume
yeah tracy's great trace um we know you
know my business partner owns a record
label so
a lot of the country music world is
kind of you know
very close by proxy so trace
um i mean he's trace is the nicest
kindest gentle giant you've ever met um
he uh and i think the idea there because
he's such an
you you recognize him so easily in
movies and stuff and i really wanted to
hide that as much as possible and take
away some of his toughness so when you
first meet him he's in the overalls we
we put his hair up under a wig and he
you know put him in a hole so he didn't
seem as imposing and uh it was
you know put him behind him in the frame
so it was
there was a lot that went into hiding
his uh
the height on trey's
um and i i my wife jokes that when he
gets on the horse you know
the the saddle leans a little bit but he
um
it was uh trace was fantastic and you
know just
i think everyone on set it was really
fun because you know like tim especially
nobody would ever go to their trailers
everyone just wanted to hang out and and
really enjoy their time and and so it
was it was a lot of fun
we had a great great cast
i'm impressed you had trailers because i
know you shot this on an independent
budget
at the same time the the production
values are so great from the costumes
and you know the hair and the makeup how
did you go about achieving such
authenticity from top to bottom
on an independent budget
i i think really just really good crew
um
you know brianna quick was our uh
wardrobe stylist and so she
i mean she was amazing everything was
that was the big thing is you know you
see some of these films and
and it's the shirt to look too clean or
whatever so she really spent time
just making everything feel thick and
and dirty and you know like he hadn't he
hadn't washed his clothes in a week and
when he did it was in the creek you know
it's it's that kind of
that kind of feel to the in the texture
to the clothing so
um and then you know hair makeup were
amazing production every everyone
i think everyone
really enjoyed the project and and just
put in so much work
um
and really felt ownership in in what
they did and i think that's a big piece
of it
tim for you you can prepare so much for
a roll before arriving on set but how
much does it help to actually put on
those costumes and i actually don't know
how extensive the hair and makeup was on
you because it looks so natural um but
how much does that ultimately help you
find that character well there was a lot
of consultation with rihanna quick about
the wardrobe and and with also with
potsie
uh and
i have you know i was preparing for this
role for
about nine months uh and a lot of that
time
um
was spent uh
in advance working with david atherton
who's this incredible
makeup artist with whom i've worked
about a dozen times now and whom potsie
thankfully agreed to bring him on to the
movie uh to to head up the department
and
uh
david and i
did extensive work
really looking at the picture of billy
the kid
uh reading about him
um you know the teeth were very
particular of the drooping eye
and we really wanted to find a way
to to make that work from the inside of
me out
rather than at all seeming to be
um applique
and so again
thanks to potsie and his wonderful
producers
uh david and i were able to get to set
weeks early and work every day
realizing what we've been talking about
for months
and finding it with
all the time we needed to be able to do
that so that it can be put
in front of potsie
and he could make sure that
it was also what he wanted
um so it was a really really good
process again so much of what works
about this movie is because
um potsie and his producers
allowed things to happen the way they
should
particularly on an independent time
independent independent film
when you don't have a lot of money
but you can have a lot of time
if people are willing to give it and um
uh they were
and so
we were able to work really patiently
and realize uh
this character
can i ask about the shooting schedule
because i heard a rumor about the
ridiculous amount of days that you had
on this and i just want to confirm it
we had uh 21 days
and it's funny because when tim signed
on he said how many do you have i said i
think we had 23 at the
time 18. we had eight that's right and
tim was like i think you know i think we
need 25 and i was like i i want to do
25. and
the producers hearing tim ask
if tim asked who we got it so we had 25
and then after we did the budget we had
and then
going into shooting we had 22 and i
actually lost one more they took one
more away from me
halfway through shooting so we had to
kind of adjust our schedule
um so it was it was and it was coveted
and it was winter so that daylight hours
were
you know a lot shorter so it was um
it was a tough tough schedule
but i i don't i mean i feel like we got
every you know i i
i would love to have a little more time
in certain places but you know i think i
think we were able to move quick and
really get everything so
um
it worked out
so for each of you what ended up being
the biggest challenge on making the film
and it can be you know a particular
scene it could be something in
preparation it could just be you know
coming back and dealing with new coveted
restrictions which i think we're still
kind of navigating
you want to go first
you know with me i guess it was two
aspects of it one was when i was reading
the script and learned
uh as the audience does um
that this guy was actually billy the kid
that
brought up a lot of questions for me
about my own suitability for the role
because
i'm not a violent person
um
and
i'm generally a
forgiving person
uh and i
and
and i don't own any guns you know there
was
even though i grew up in oklahoma um it
just the distance between that character
and me
is
quite
uh long
and
i didn't wanna
show up on popsy's set and disappoint
him
and so
it was it was really you know the
challenge was can i actually do this
i can play a strict father
but when it comes to
to to the violence
um
both spiritually and also physically
handling the guns
and it's not just one gun it's many guns
uh and
doing so
in a minimalist and unyielding way
rather than in a showy way or histrionic
way
felt like
space i'd never occupied
um
and and so that scared me uh luckily
there was a lot of prep time
and then the other issue was the
emotional
places that he goes by the end of the
movie
um
and again time was a
was a big ally just having a lot of time
with the role
and being able to work on it every day
for months and months really take
the care
that i knew posse was going to need
because this is a director's medium
and you want to come through for your
director um
and uh
he had a lot of skin in the game epoxy
and i just didn't want to up i
wanted to be good for him
um and so uh
you know the physical and emotional
realities of playing this guy
that was those were the big challenges
for for me
yeah well first of all tim you didn't
you did the opposite of up you were
amazing so and i think everybody else
agrees
so
um
i guess
you know there's two pieces of it that
were that stand out the most one was
just the weather
i mean we were you know this was
30 degree weather and
it was
especially the night when uh
when dugan comes to
attack and he's under the under the
porch and tim has to
beat him up in the yard that was
that was one of the coldest nights we
had and you know we had this
12 by kind of keeping some rain off us
but we had to move it we started
shooting
and just i mean these guys were rolling
around the mud just freezing cold and
the crew is all wet and
you know those are some those are some
tough moments um
but i think the biggest
the thing that was the most difficult
for me was that
i guess just going into that last
shootout
and and really trying to figure out
you know
what those sequences were going to be
and what how that was going to work and
and the you know because then
the idea the last moment was going to be
tim's character and stephen dorff's
character having a hand-to-hand battle
ending in the creek where tim drowns him
and we tested the water and it turned
out it had a coli in it so we had to
uh two days
two days before and then there was a
question of can we just do it anyway but
that didn't
not allowed to do that so um two days
before actually i had to rewrite that
scene
and so
it was just you know it's it's that
okay
what's going to be as good in that
moment and what you know how how can you
make this
a good scene and what are the angles and
how are the stunts going to work and
because you know we had a great film up
to this point and this was late in the
shoot schedule and so it's like
you don't want to mess up in those
moments i think that was those are the
most stressful moments for me is the
shootout in the action and i think the
ones i tried to prep them most for a
cram at the last minute but
so
that's so fun to hear
and you just happened at the last minute
to come up with one of the great
shootouts ever
i was just gonna say the shootout is so
perfect i can't even imagine it any
other way
i know i can't either
well again congratulations on such a
fantastic movie i want to remind
everyone watching at home it's available
video on demand
so you can watch it again which i highly
recommend when you watch it a second
time knowing um it's not just all about
the twist but it is really fun to see
the seeds that are sort of planted
throughout thank you so so much for
watching at home and thank you both so
much for being here
yeah thank you us a lot of fun thank you
[Music]